is it recording that's recording it's  recording okay hi hey so this is I'm  putting up a random video on my channel  because guess what I can do that I  mentioned in my video tomorrow how think  filet M for a million subscribers on  this channel but I just wanted to make  an extra special video just like talking  about it um because it is its caveman  speak for a really emotional plots so I  just want you guys to all know that and  it's only been two and a half weeks on  this channel and I hope you don't get  tired of this channel I hope they you  enjoy it and I hope you enjoy all of the  new things that are coming your way  issue I don't know I don't know what's  happening I don't know I'm just I'm I'm  overwhelmed by internet feels and I'm  very happy to be a part of the YouTube  community and that's it I don't know go  on with your what day of the week is it  Wednesday Wed nest day why is there a D